on the Rings war in the north it's an
action RPG and there's a lot of things
that make it different from both I think
other RPGs that have come over recent
years and also from any other Lord of
the Rings game that's come recently as
well firstly I mean it's by snowblind
studios so a decade ago they defined
action RPGs on console with baldur's
gate dark alliance and the essence of
that genre is really fun action focused
RPG lots of loot lots of exploration
lots of upgrading and also co-op so the
ability to play with your friends either
online or locally so it's very very much
the spiritual successor to that game but
updated for a new generation and then as
a lord of the rings game it's very much
able to go beyond the movies so it's not
a movie game we're able to create a new
story we're able to let players explore
parts of middle-earth they haven't been
to before and then able to put those two
things together so really a genuinely
next-generation action RPG experience
and then combine that with the greatest
richest most detailed fantasy universe
ever created and going beyond the movie
license with that what we're really
excited to reveal in the e3 demo is as
well as the three playable characters
which are the heart of the fellowship
there's a fourth character who's a
really key ally almost extension of the
fellowship in the game and that's belair
arm he's one of the great Eagles so he's
being held prisoner by AG and au being
tormented by these evil orcs and you
rescue him which gets his allegiance and
his assistance in helping you against
this enemy so you can call him during
battle to sweep down and you know wreak
devastation against against your enemies
and he's particularly powerful against
huge enemies big bosses that your face
like the orcs and trolls
so on so very very powerful ally to
having combat again
I think in a way by moving away from the
movies it's being true to the experience
of talking because as you read or see
The Hobbit as you read Lord of the Rings
it's a constant journey of discovery
through those books you're constantly
visiting new places seeing amazing new
monsters discovering new characters so
it's really trying to be close to the
essence of that experience and actually
take players on another on a new journey
of discovery through middle-earth it's
going to be this year it's going to be
2011 and it's going to be on PlayStation
3 x 360 and PC